[Music]
let's talk about Funimation FEMA's okay
so guys to be precise with you I'll be
talking more efficiently involve in will
start automation but as that's a part of
that initial basic so finances give you
a basic knowledge of it that what
automation framework is and then you see
all we will be going to create a
framework so first of all what is
automation framework so it's a set of
protocols rules such as coding standards
object repository and data handle and
beneficial in terms of code leaves
portability maintenance the pre will
provide the basis of this automation
simplifies the automation effort so what
happens actually when we need this
automation suppose you are automating
only one functionality you have written
only one test script of course you don't
require to write an automation framework
for this because there's only one script
if there is any there is any change
comes you can go ahead and make the
change and done but when this one is
this script one one automation script
becomes 100 then it becomes very
difficult to manage them
suppose in 100 tasks is 100 scripts
there is a username there is a password
so there is a reasonable password and
more than 10 test scripts and that
happens then and if there is any change
comes in the password or in the username
you may have to go to the tenth take
script separately and make change which
will be very cumbersome process and it
may be possible that you make you made
an error okay it may be possible that Q
know somewhere you have written
something different some yogurt from the
different or spilling error or space
error may have also if I talked about
what you have done up treating your
scripts but that is keeping in mind for
big groups
but what if you have to write our Linux
and we'll go back on all your scripts to
make that change what if you have
written your script for Firefox browser
and you may have to run it for Chrome
browser then it will be difficult to
make multiple changes so it's always
suggested that you create a framework
for that because flavor is the one which
will help you out and solve all these
problems instead of writing one thing
again and again we will write it only at
one place and reuse that again and again
it will be very easy for us to maintain
it because that in terms of frameworks
that's in the framework where you can
make changes very easily portability so
of course you have written out of
windows and you can try it on any other
operating system the framework provides
the basis of test automation and
simplifies the automation effort it is
actually helpful when you have multiple
scripts from multiple test cases so
framework is very important this the
reason if you go and say that you have
done the automation on you have a
knowledge of automation it will always
ask you about DP they will know go they
will not go in the basics they will
always go with the automation so it's
very important so what are the
automation frameworks do we have we have
linear free involve in structured
framework data driven framework keyboard
ribbon vibratory there are multiple
types of frameworks we have this team
methodology for automation first of all
you know methylation is how you decide
whether you need to automate more so
first of all you take a decision whether
this project needs to be automated or
not because that is becoming very
complex you have 10 methodology you have
Ness resources all those things you have
less matured because of that we thought
you oughta make that when you have
thought of automating it what do you
want is you think on that so you pick 3
to 4 tools it certainly depends you pick
3 to 4 tools create a proof of concept
create a proof of concept phase I you
all aware produce proof of concept POC a
base aware of that anyway
with not aware of that can see engineers
hard of it crucial is aware of that
great not created on my own yes let's
perfectly fine approach for theorists
ago says no because what is proof of
concept is whenever you are suppose your
shortlisting symposium multiple
automation who's in the market correct
so how do you decide whether which who
is best for you of course you can go
ahead and you know take a list of goods
you can see drawers and cons of those
leads but those pros and cons will be
tools depending on the bloggers the
betting on the editor who is writing
about that particular tool it may not
have the cable it may not be possible
that those advantages or disadvantages
are actually correct for your project so
always what we do we shortlist few tools
like free report rules we develop or
create if you see ready POC needs you
actually use those tools to automate one
simple skill use all three to lose what
you have shortlisted to automate a
simple script and then figure out the
pros and cons of that tool based on your
experience and based on what other
people see and then you create a PPD and
show it to the management and this is
the tools we have taken up this is the
PUC this is how it works this is the
advantage this is a registered Vantage
and then you shortlist one tool out of
it and this would be called test to
acquisition and it does not like you are
talking and we are the lungs array and
you will go ahead and say selenium and
that's it they will accept it no you
have to tell them that this is the PUC
and this is the benefits of opting
selenium tool and then if they are happy
with that then they will go ahead with
that they will say goodbye yes they may
ask you to come back off for the good
videos and all this stuff okay and it
becomes very difficult to you know
impress your management when there is an
existing tool running like qtp is
running and you wanted to suggest then
selenium to then we could become very
difficult because they may say that
although the projects were working
perfectly fine with the community why
should we go ahead with selenium
what is the best part so that's what you
need to highlight and need to say that
these are the things we want to meet
with review selenium you can do so
that's where testable acquisition comes
then you do the test planning that what
all disk is should be automated and we
start developing your test cases our
test experience then you execute them
and manage them then you show the result
of all those test cases and send it with
all the stakeholders then this is the
result cool
what the automation lifecycle now so far
you must have seen software testing
lifecycle software development lifecycle
but now today you have seen automation
lifecycle hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos turner up and get
certified click here